Hey, what's going on? It's bill burn. It's
the Monday morning podcasts for Monday.
Uh,
the hell month is it?
May 21st, 2012. What's
going on? How are you?
Did you have a nice weekend?
Are you looking for,
it's a memorial day.
Do my buddy's got a fucking boat kid?
We're going to get out there with
some fucking boy. Wise's dude,
guys weekend. Fuck the ladies. Um,
yeah, that's coming up
right? I had no idea.
I had no idea that next week was
a three day weekend. You know,
because I'm a comedian. Every week's
a three day weekend, you know,
I don't have shit to do. I
just sit around now. Actually,
I've been working my ass off.
I just did. You know, I didn't,
but I've got offered to
do another episode of a,
of Glee. They liked what I did so
much last season. It's a possibility.
It's not a definite,
all right,
so I'm already a going to my vocal coach,
you know,
just working out some songs,
I'm a dreamer or does it go,
you know, they probably turn
that into like a melody, right?
They'd start singing that and then
they'd go into another one. Right?
I had to run away.
Hi Mca.
Why do they always do that? And then
the crowd always goes, oh my God,
it's a different, I didn't
see that. They, Dave,
they connect all those Sears.
I have both those songs on my iPod and
I just never saw how they connected.
It took a bunch of twinkle toes
and a cafeteria to show them.
They're always singing in a cafeteria.
What is the deal with that?
What's the deal with gay
people? Sooner? Goober. Dude.
Is there something for my, yeah, my
gay listeners out there. Do you guys,
do you guys feel the need to sing
whenever you're in a cafeteria?
Is that what it is? You know,
come up to the football players.
Semi bent at the waist. Snapping your
fingers, moving your arms vertically,
don't you? Of course you don't, right?
Isn't that TV's version of what you do?
You just like us. You're looking
for a closet to rub one out. Okay.
Except you thinking different shit.
See that?
Bringing people together on the podcast.
Speaking of a singing,
I'm going to order this thing.
You guys know that I hate
country music. You know, I,
I liked the oldest shit.
I don't like the new stuff where
they just pander to their audience.
You know what I mean? I lock
America puppies, you know, lock it.
We're going to put a boot in your ass or
whatever that fucking jerk off is with
the hat pulled down over his face. Almost
like he's ashamed of what he's singing.
Okay.
Ah, what the fuck is, wow. What
the hell is his name is? Oh,
Toby, Keith, Toby, Keith,
that guy. All right.
He always has that hat pulled down low.
You know,
he's a man yet he's wearing chaps. I
like that guy, that guy. And he's got,
he's a Lotta Lotta Lotta
like contradictions, you
know what I mean? He's like,
you know, rough and tumble
guy, yet he's wearing chaps,
like the guy in the village people and uh,
he looked like a racist yet. His
first name is Toby, you know,
which I think is a shout out to roots.
So you know, I can't figure that guy out.
Um, anyways, so I was watching
this a risk commercial.
They had like 150 of of a
country music's greatest duets,
you know, a lamb, Dell
apartment, Conrad Twitty.
That was the only guy I found creepy.
I don't know if he was
nervous that he was on TV,
but he would not move a
fucking muscle on his face.
And he had this just as big fucking,
I don't know, pork shoulder
fucking head, you know what I mean?
Like if he had shoulder of Bison,
like the size that he had a big fucking,
you know,
just 40 years before P90x no
guy was doing cardio. Right.
All you doing is yanking your fucking
pants up or pushing them down and he's
singing some fucking song
about some girlies with, I can't, I can't
remember how the whole metal he went.
But it was something to the effect of
being a locking tail when I hold you let,
you'd never been this far before,
something like that. It was,
she had something to do with him holding
this trembling virgin in his arms as he
sat there with this
fucking 600 yard stare,
like he's waiting for Charlie to come
over the fucking wire, you know? Um,
or let,
like maybe he was like confessing
to being a sexual Predator and like,
he was just waiting for the FBI to come
out and just arrest him in the middle of
singing that song. You know, like after
a while you just want to get caught.
Isn't that something that they do?
I'm not saying that he's a sex offender.
I wouldn't say that. All I
can say is before he got his
perm, he looked like one,
you know, he had that Elvis
just going straight back,
but just a giant fucking head.
Just a huge head.
Um,
you know,
he looked like he looked like he was
already murdered and was fished out of a
lake.
Okay.
Just a fucking bloated,
gigantic head and he wasn't moving.
He looked like dead dead fucking thing on
the other first men in black. Oh, right,
Bill. We got it. He's got an
awful head. Well, fuck you.
I got a whole hour to fill here. I'm
only six minutes in, so you do it, Huh?
And your cubicle. Somebody sent
me the creepiest, creepiest,
yeah. Email last week.
They said, hey, you know,
did you ever know anybody who jerked
off in a cubicle.dot. Dot. Well,
now you do.
You know,
and it's not that he
jerked off in a cubicle.
It's the fact that he emailed me his
name, his email, all of that shit.
It's just like, I mean, uh,
you're playing a dangerous game.
Maybe you want to get caught,
sir. Is that what it is?
Do you habitually jerk off
and you're fucking cubicle?
What if that went to the wrong person?
What if you sent that to your boss?
And he just got done
yelling at you saying,
you need to need to show some initiative
in 20 minutes later, you know,
he gets an email from you. And
he's like, all right, maybe, uh,
maybe it finally stuck and I
don't have to fire this guy.
And he opens it up and he says,
hey,
did you ever know anybody jerked off in
a cubicle.dot. Dot. Well, now you do.
Okay.
Maybe meant to send it to his boss. I
mean, that was his way of going out,
you know,
just fucking impregnated
his laptop and walked out.
Nah, there's no way he did that.
How could you ever get another job?
There's no way around that. Um, anyways,
it's Monday morning and I'm doing
the podcast and for new listeners,
I know what you're thinking.
Well,
I live in fucking a Scandinavia and
it's not Monday morning over here,
but listen, I don't care.
I don't give a fuck.
The only Monday morning I
care about is in my time zone.
It's nine 17 in the morning.
All right.
Those douchebags on those morning
shows are still on being Sassy,
showing spunk. You know,
those are all morning words,
you know what I mean? Nobody has get up
and go at 6:00 PM. Right. That's all.
That's all 6:00 AM shit. Uh, she,
she's just a firecracker, right?
Nobody says that if 5:00 PM
Ron quit and tech, you know,
we got just, well, why do I these,
you know what this podcast is just
to be me stating the fucking obvious.
Um,
how much for a drive
yesterday and my Prius,
um, somebody, actually,
some are redneck guy,
was talking to me about my Prius go
and you know them things ain't, oh no,
they don't do anything for the
environment. You realize that don't you?
I mean them batteries and batteries,
they putting them cars, you know,
long it takes for them to break down.
Ooh, let me tell you they're doing that.
They're actually,
they're actually doing more damage
there and then I can have a regular gas
combustion, Corey, you know, telling
me all that shit. You know what I mean?
Half of it's true. The other half, he's
like making up as he's going along,
you know, almost like he's talking about
the big game. Then he never played in,
in high school, but there's no one
around that he went to school with.
So now he's quarterback.
Right. And a, I know it,
a lot of people listening right now
gone. That's actually true. All right.
I don't give a fuck. Okay. I never
said I was saving the planet.
Did I? I don't think I did. I
probably did. I'm hypocritical. Um,
okay.
I see it. There's nothing you could,
everybody should be, you know,
if there was the right amount
of human beings on this planet,
we could all drive tanks and it would
have no effect on the ozone layer.
Alright? That's my new philosophy.
Stop trying to make cars,
have better gas mileage.
Tried to have less people driving them.
Okay?
Oh Jesus.
Is this my final solution?
So many fucking people. People.
That's what the problem is. All right.
It ain't the cars. Cars don't
kill the ozone layer of people do.
Um, anyways, I get them into the biggest,
dumbest fucking fight last
night with my girl. Right?
We had this great day. You know, it
was on the road again. I could do,
do, do, do up above.
Oh, hear that. Hear that
you that bump up bub bub bub.
That's what I have to have it on.
If for some reason that that noise that
alert on my phone doesn't freak out my
dog,
but every other sound on it freaks out
my dog and it starts fucking shaking like
a goddamn junkie.
And a,
that is an embarrassing tone to have
when you're walking around with your
friends,
you know,
and it always comes on when you're in
the middle of some story that you're
exaggerating what you really did. So I
walk up to the guy and I'm like, no buddy.
Fuck you.
You want to take a fucking swing here?
I'll give you the first punch
right here. Body pump, pump
pump, pump, pump. Yeah, no,
fuck it. Then it goes down
the Goddamn damn toilet. Um,
so anyways,
the hell did we do yesterday?
Okay.
Oh, we went out to Brunch, right?
I had already eaten breakfast,
so she got a brunch and
I got up here and uh,
some guy next to me
with the big red beard.
He'd been growing it for like nine years.
It was like Zz top level,
I think a little bit longer. It was
like reverse crystal Gayle, you know,
like don't like the guy version
of it up as a redhead and uh,
so whatever. And then I'm like, Hey, you
know, let's go for a drive. She's like,
I want to go to some shops. Let's just
walk down the street, you know that,
and they grab your arm and you're
just sitting there, you know,
walking down the street,
just thinking what have I just elbowed
him in the ribs and ran across the street,
you know, right there, that fucking
bar now was actually a good time.
And then after that it was like,
you know,
I will always fly out lax and I always
see the beach and up in Malibu and Santa
Barbara and all that type of shit.
And I'm like, you know, it's,
I sh we should fucking shut
that part of the city out.
So we drive over there and the Prius,
that's not saving the environment,
but getting great gas mileage,
great gas mileage. Um,
and we fucking get up there and what a
bunch of Douche bags up there. All right.
I got to shut my phone off.
What the fuck? Bump. Bump.
What the hell is it? You know what, that's
just going to go off in the background.
Yeah,
we put it on mute here. Don't you wish
there was a mute button for people?
What's the deal? Um, yes, we go
up there. What a bunch of cons.
What a bunch of cons
live in fucking Malibu.
I want to go up there and I was
trying to find like their town center,
I don't even know if they
have one or what, but every,
it's all gated communities to
keep out the riff raff. Like me,
I can't even drive by and just look at
their houses, you know? So what happened?
Whenever we're having a good
time, we drive back, we're
going through the canyons.
I pull over on the side of the road,
we buy strawberries off some guy who
claims to be an organic farmer, right?
Privately stolen from a trader
Joe's who gives a shit, right?
Everything's going great. So I stay in,
take a night off from comedy and I say,
Hey, why don't we watch, why don't we
watch your movie? You know what I mean?
Cap Off this wonderful fucking
day. Everything's going
great. What could go wrong?
This is like the beginning of a horror
movie where they just show like the
perfect family and everything's great
and people are wearing like white linen,
you know?
And then all of a sudden they just start
showing the camera and the bushes like
a POV of like Mike Myers. This
is basically what happens.
So 60 minutes comes on,
right? Who doesn't want to watch that
show and pretend they're smart? You know,
I like it some more Morley
safer comes on and you know,
we smells like an old person. Some old
people don't smell like old people,
but he looks like he smells
like an old person, you know,
smells of cigars, ash trays,
you know, couple of wars,
maybe a date rape.
Um,
so he's interviewing Meryl Streep.
All right.
The Great Meryl Streep when they're going
through all our own oral frigging life
and all the movies and all the different
characters that she's played. Oh,
first of all,
they start,
they start the report off with
Morley safer just sitting there.
Right. Smelling a fucking
Ben Gay in Whiskey, right?
And he says, how, you
know, wow, over in England,
you know, they, you know, I dunno,
they make their, their actors,
they, they award them by calling
them lords and they night them.
But over here in America,
all we do is just give him the
shiny statue and it's just like,
starts off right off the bat for
some reason just shitting on America.
I don't know why like an
Oscar is somehow beneath,
okay
sir. Uh, Anthony Michael
Hall. I mean, or, or Lord,
what it Lord of what,
what are what
lease. You can fucking hold our
statue, your lord of what kingdom,
that phony horse shit that you have
with Prince Charles and the popper or
whatever the fuck is going on over there.
You know,
look up the Rothschilds night you over
there, then that fucking means something.
Then you can come become
part of their yacht.
Convoy is they go around the world
figuring out how to take over another
currency, right? Then you're in with them,
okay. But if you're, if you're fucking,
you know, Lord of this and your, your
wing man is the Duke of Elton John.
I mean that's the whole thing is fucking
stupid, right? So right off the bat,
it's already bugging me. But I know Nia
hates when I talk to the TV, right? So,
you know,
I keep my big fucking Yap shut and they
start talking about Meryl Streep up a
Papaya,
gone through the whole thing.
And then I'm the old guy
there smelling of a, you know,
prescription meds goes, uh,
you know, whenever they talk
about the roles you play,
they always say, you know, he
play independent minded women,
very strong women and Merrill goals. I
know that's, yeah, that's what they say.
You know, when a guide,
they never say to a guy, oh,
you're playing a strong willed character,
Yadda Yadda Yadda. I let that go.
Whatever, no biggie. I'll
take that. It's probably true.
The fuck do I know I'm not a woman.
Right.
But then they show her after
she played Margaret Thatcher,
and she's given a speech to a bunch of
women's young girls and she's trying to
inspire them and she,
she takes a quote from Margaret Thatcher.
It was something along the lines of,
if you want a bunch of
people to talk around,
talk is standing around talking
about doing something, you know,
something a go, yeah,
you got to talk to men,
but if you want it to actually get done,
you got to get a woman.
And then all the chicks go,
whoo, like flipping out. Right?
So I laughed and I'm like,
Yay. Reverse sexism. Right.
Just seeing,
you know,
my, my whole fucking theory, how
everybody is just a piece of shit.
You just don't have the power to act
out what the fuck you want to do because
that, that right there, if
you flip that around as a guy,
if you're running for president,
it's fucking over. He can't be like,
let me tell you.
I'll tell you what,
after I get you jobs and after
I fixed this economy, okay.
And I'm the man to do it
because I'll tell you right now,
if you're looking for someone to stand
around and talk about doing something,
you get a woman. You want to get
it done. You got to get a man,
here are my nuts right here on the podium,
volt from me,
November 4th go fuck
yourself. Right? You did that.
Your presidential campaigns over.
She does it. It's fucking adorable.
And it's just this fucking ignorant,
you know what I mean?
What a fuck do you get off saying
that we stand around and do nothing.
Meryl Streep. Ah, or quoting Margaret
and youtube. Margaret Thatcher
me tastes you bitches something. Alright,
we faked a fucking lunar landing. Okay.
You think that's just talking. Anybody
can land on the fucking moon. That's easy.
But to pretend you did it all right and
get everybody to shut the fuck up about
it. That, that, that, that right
there, that takes skill. So whatever.
So I make that little comment and um, did
I just go with that? That, that, that,
that, that's the only
fucking porky pig. So,
so I make that comment and like,
you know,
I've been with Nia long enough that I
can tell by the side of her face when
she's just thinking about like,
what if I just grabbed everything I
really cared about and walked out of this
house right now.
She got like that fucking mad at me,
you know?
And I'm like,
she's just like right
after the story was over,
she just shut the fucking thing
off. And uh, I don't happen to,
cause now I'm walking to seven 11 to get
some ice cream. I haven't, I've not even,
what happened was all going great.
You know,
I might be asshole there.
What am I?
Am I supposed to just fucking sit there
with my mouth hanging open with drill
coming out when I watch TV,
if somebody says something Douchey,
I'm not supposed to say it.
Okay.
Yeah, whatever, whatever.
So I just finally just said,
you know what? Fuck this.
I take the dog out. I go
around the block. What do I do?
I'm calling my guy friends,
right? They're all backing me up.
I'm not saying who I called,
I don't name names. Right.
And they're all laughing their ass
off and they 100% agree with me,
which is all I'm looking
for at this point.
I just want people to say that I'm right.
I don't want to learn
anything from this experience.
Just tell me I was right so I
can be an ignorant ass again.
I don't know. Why don't you guys weigh
in on that? Am I a Dick for saying that?
Should I just let that one go? You
know? Ah You know what she said?
That fucking drove me up the
wall. She goes, why are you,
she didn't seem intimidated.
She used one of those words.
Why you threatened by what she said.
It's like I'm not threatened.
I Yeah Jesus Christ.
Then I take the bait,
you know it just sends me right over day
like threatened about what? Oh my God,
this person that I don't know who has
never called me nor will ever call me,
who has no effect on my life.
How do you get threatened by that?
I'm just calling it for the bullshit
that it is, cause you know what?
This is what fucking drives me nuts.
I can't stand when somebody tells me
that they're shit sandwich tastes worse
than my shit sandwich.
Okay, go fuck yourself.
At what point am I supposed
to have empathy as I'm
sitting here eating the shit
sandwich and you're telling me how much
worse your yours, yours, this, you know,
at the end of the fucking day. You know
what I mean? Sure. Mine might be on a,
you know,
a better slice of bread,
which I guess would make it
taste a little bit better,
but at the end of the fucking day,
right the end of the fucking day.
All right, I'm going to end up
in a FEMA camp with you. Okay?
You think when the next fucking psycho
comes along, I'm going to make the cut.
What the fuck do I, what do I
bring to the world? Huh? Exactly.
I'll be standing right next to you. So
go fuck yourself. You just fucking woman.
Every time she sneezes,
they give her another God damn award.
She's still pitching. Still fucking
bitching. You know it's rough.
I remember when I did
this Oscar nominated part.
Oh go fuck yourself with your wigs.
The whole thing. Just, you know,
that's what fucking pisses me
off when I watched this shit.
If you really want to know my
perspective is from where I come from,
I can't bitch about shit cause
everybody's like, oh go fuck yourself.
You hit the lottery. Right. But I got
to sit here and listen to you bitch.
Even if you fucking killing it,
even if you're killing it,
you know Yale School of drama
and he's still up on the bull.
Go Fuck yourself with your
God damn yachts. All right,
there you go. That felt good. It
was probably ignorant, but whatever.
Um, all right, let's get to a,
and let's get some advertising
now that I trashed. Um,
Lord Meryl Streep. What did, what does
she call, is she a prince princess?
Is that what it is?
Okay.
You know what,
if I ever get to that fucking level,
which God knows I'm not going to cause
you have to have an unbelievable body of
work by the time you're my age.
Okay.
You know,
to even remotely have a shot and then
they're not going to give it to you until
you're like fucking 60.
So that's a, that's out,
that's out the door.
That's like when I wanted to go to
Notre Dame when I was in high school,
I wanted to go to that college
and by my sophomore year,
I knew that that dream was over.
And
so the same goes for
ever getting knighted,
but let's just say for some fucking
reason, they lowered the standards
and I get knighted.
Right.
Okay.
Um, or asked to be knighted. Like
that's some shit I'm not showing up.
Why would you show up for that?
You know, do, do you want to,
do you want to get knighted
in our a fake kingdom?
You know, uh, I dunno, but who am
I gonna get knighted by fucking,
I'm mister McFeely. Is that what I'm
going to do? A, you're fucking Weirdos.
Okay.
Why don't you guys fuck outside of your
gene pool and then maybe I'll show up to
become a sergeant and your little fucking,
uh, that's what, that's that whole,
that whole royal family like
a bunch of God damn rednecks.
She's my third cousin blow me.
Okay.
It's why they were all weird looking.
Prince Charles is a weird
look and son of a bitch.
Look at his fuck is awful teeth.
Those ears. He really does.
He looks like a, he's missing
some parts. You know what I mean?
He looks like, you know, if you have like
a fucking 66 Mustang and then you gee,
he looks like the, the piece of shit
one that they're not going to restore.
And everybody, you know, everybody going
in there taking carburetors out and uh,
radiators and shit. He looks like
he's missing some stuff. You know,
Princess Di was hot though. She
was hot. She had big feet though.
Didn't she had big feet right now of
losing anybody gay listening to this.
Right. That's like their, uh,
that's there. Jesus. I think,
isn't it that a fucking why do I
try? All right, let's, let's get,
let's get on with the advertising
here. Um, what do we got here?
What do we got? Oh, let's
go. Oh, you know what?
In honor of Memorial Day weekend,
this is a big man holiday,
right? We got to sit there and
act like you don't cry sometimes.
Do yourself late at
night. Um, what, what do,
what are you gonna do this weekend?
Huh? You're going to get some alcohol.
You're going to rent a boat,
you're going to hit a rock
and then say he didn't see it.
And then there's going to be some sort
of big insurance claim or you could stay
on the land and he can, you
can, you can grill, you know,
and I'm not just saying what that normal
grill that you have that you've been
using for years with those little
skinny Pretzel Rod, you know,
great state you have on it. You know
what you need. You need the man. Great.
All right. For this weekend. All
right. And if not for this weekend,
you can do it for father's
day is the copy says, yeah.
Why don't you hook up your dad for
once you dad never gets anything. Okay?
This father's day, there's only
one perfect gift, all right?
Cause every other gift you get him,
he's going to throw it in your face.
You want to get them this right here.
It's the man,
great grill enhancement system.
What's the man? Great you ask. Well,
I'm glad you asked that because I have
the answers in this copy right here, man.
Grates are 100% made in America.
Cast iron, grilling greats.
All right? And all you do is you just
take off your little pretzel rod once.
You know what I mean? This is
like putting like a, you know,
yanking out the awful engine and
putting a bigger one in. All right?
You take off your old ones and you
slam this one down. All right, there.
These are heavy duty
grilling grades to deliver a,
exactly what you need to achieve the
steakhouse flavor you've been looking for
with the mangroves, patented
design, chicken states or veggies.
We'll have never tasted so good.
No more flare ups. No more dry
meant, you mean no more
dry meat guaranteed. Uh,
take advantage of our $20 Monday morning
podcast special today by clicking on
the man great banner@billboard.com.
Um, as a bonus,
every billboard.com order comes with
a heavy duty man Greg grilling brush.
All right? They're made in America.
They're cast iron. It's really cool man.
They got like these uh,
these little catches so when the grease
comes down it stays in like the little
moat there so it doesn't
flare up and cause uneven
cooking in that type of thing.
And you know the deal. Okay. This
weekend or given it to you dad,
you want to make the best steak on
the block? It's, it's a guy thing.
It taps into the caveman in every man.
Okay.
And you got your dad came up when guys
were guys, so he's going to love it.
All right? It's steak house
quality grilling in backyard.
You get $20 off a,
you go to billboard.com.
You Click on the podcast page and
you'll see the man. Great thing.
You Click on that and you get $20 off.
There you go. Let's Hook up dad for once.
Huh?
Does your dad's stand around and talk
about grilling the steak and then your mom
comes in and gets it done? I
don't think so. Margaret Thatcher.
MMM.
Anyways, you know, stuff that
Margaret Thatcher and that,
that chick who view the
original cook on TV,
they look the exact same as
far as I'm concerned. You know,
and Meryl Streep,
she won awards for both parts.
You know what I mean? Did she
still complaining? You know what,
she wasn't really complaining.
She brought that one point and I totally
blew it out of proportion and that's
what the fuck I do. All right.
All right. So now that I, I,
I did a little advertising that is a
couple of things that I actually wanted to
bring up that have nothing to do
with advertising just to two awesome,
uh, youtube channels that, um,
okay.
That I found,
you know,
now that I've got a house and I've been
trying to learn how to fix shit because
you feel like a moron,
you don't want some other guy has to come
over and rescue you from your problems.
Um, that Dude El Cheapo.
I tweeted about this guy,
uh, I'm going to have a link
to a, one of his, uh, his,
his youtube channel is to shit.
This guy can fix anything.
Plays Guitar. This guy, he's like the
macgyver. He's like a bargain basement.
Macgyver. I don't mean he's
bargain basement. I mean,
he can do anything for like no money.
He does everything for cheap.
And uh, believe me, after your,
you were in a house or something like
that or if you've got a shit job and the
bankers of fucking you in the ass,
this guy,
we'll show you how to fix anything
for cheap. It's the Shit El Cheapo.
Um, and then there's
another dude, you know,
I don't know about you guys,
but I always found car engines to second.
They turned them sideways
and it became fuel injected.
I don't even know what the fuck's
going on. This guy, Eric, the car guy,
you know, I'm telling you,
if you're a moron like me,
if you just watch this guy after
a while you start going like,
I could do that.
I could unplug all that shit.
And yanked that engine out of the car.
Same thing with El Cheapo digits
to fucking awesome channels.
And a, I probably watched just about
all of their videos at this point. Um,
okay.
Like what's his face, Eric? The car guy.
Watch that guy like for like an hour.
Okay.
Hour's worth of video is a
45 minutes with the videos.
I'm watching them change
a water pump on a 2002
Chevy cavalier or something.
What the hell? It was, um,
unreal and, but you just keep watching
it and after awhile I swear to God,
it's like you start to Geek,
you start building your confidence.
Now there's no fucking way I would
try do that on my car. All right.
But some other stuff that outskirts and
going into it a little bit wouldn't be
that bed. So there you go.
All right, let's get back.
Let's get back to the podcast.
Everybody. Um, oh, by the way,
real quick. Guess who's going to be
performing in Burbank, California? Huh?
This the city that, uh,
Johnny Carson made famous.
I'm going to be at flappers
on May 25th and 26th.
Uh, out in Burbank. Tickets
are going fast. Two shows
Friday, two shows Saturday.
I'd love you guys come down and I'm
gonna be trying out some new stuff while
also playing some classics.
How about that? You like dead.
You want an overrated for this week?
Overrated. Underrated. He's overrated.
A napkin holder, napkin holder.
Overrated. They don't fucking work.
All right. You want to make money
selling something for 1995 late at night.
Why don't you come up with a fucking
Napkin holder that works. All right.
This is the problem.
If you don't put enough napkins in there,
gravity takes over and they
fucking fall out of the thing.
So you've got to always have
to put too many in there.
So then as you go to pull them out,
they start tearing.
Then you always got to
grab like 40 of 'em out.
Take one out and stick the other thing.
And you might wanna just leave it in
that plastic hunk of shit. Really? Bill,
what are you really mad at? Oh go fuck
yourself. So this is a rough week for me.
You know what? What am I up to here? How
much, how much time is left in class?
31 minutes. All right. We're
at the halfway point. Good.
I go to the bathroom. Can
I relieve my bottles? Um,
no you can't.
You have to sit here and listen to me
pontificate about this bullshit that I
stopped caring about the
third year I taught it.
How do high school teachers do that? Teach
the same material over and over again.
You know, wonder why they always have
their hands in their pockets, you know,
rubbing that balls.
Just trying to do anything.
Okay.
Make it more, I don't know,
stimulating for him. All right, Bill,
you're not stupid is what this call is.
What's this called?
Is is what this is called bill.
I've been listen to your podcast for
the past two months and I honestly don't
think you're stupid at all.
Just the mere fact, sir, that
you have to defend me. You know,
if the gloves don't fit,
um,
you give great advice and it's not just
some hollow cookie cutter bullshit.
I Dunno about your educational background,
but you have an excess of
common sense and wisdom.
Uh,
if I have an issue,
I will definitely bring it to you and
hopes that you have advice for me.
Anyone who thinks you're retarded is
just covering up their retardation by
taking it out on you. Keep that shit
up. Thank you, sir. You know what?
That was all good to your last two
sentences and then everyone just realized
that you had the same intellect I do.
Which is why you don't think I'm dumb.
Okay.
Anyone who thinks you're retarded is
just covering up their retardation by
taking it out on you. Keep that shit
up, dude. You Ain't fucking stupid.
Keep that fucking shit up. I
appreciate that, sir. All right,
let's talk sports.
All right.
At the risk of having all the fucking
people got picked last in gym class,
wine to me on Twitter,
it's somebody's yet another person
threatened to unfollow me on Twitter if I
didn't stop tweeting about
sports threatening. You know,
if you don't stop talking about
sports, I'm going to stop. I'm,
I might stop listening to you.
I don't give a fuck.
Maybe Meryl Streep is right.
I think women just unfollow.
You guys sit in there,
they talk about it. Um,
this is my prediction
for the, uh, for the NBA.
I think the spurs are gonna win it all.
You know why the Spurs play basketball?
The way your dad fights,
you know he's, your dad is
too old to fuck around. Okay.
He's just going to end it with the
fucking throat shop is just sitting there
trying to do some Floyd Mayweather
shit that you saw on TV. Okay.
That's what's happening to
the La Clippers right now.
I don't even know if they're still, even
if they got swept or not, it was three,
three, zip last I saw watching them.
They would just do it. You know
the fucking clippers.
They're out there. Lake Boom,
trying to throw fucking alley. Oops.
And Shit. Goddamn spurs are sitting in,
half of them are fucking bald.
It just sitting there picking
and rolling them to do
death.
You know, every 14 year old kid at some
point squares off with his dad. Like,
all right, I've had enough of your shit.
Old Man. Right. And what does he do?
Fucking hit you with some shitty
learned in the navy and it's over in two
seconds.
You sitting there watching the UFC and
rolling around on the Mat thinking you
know some shit. You don't. All right,
okay.
This is the thing about old guys.
They're very fucking efficient.
Tim Dunkin doesn't have time for
your fucking bullshit. All right?
He's going to score as many as he needs
to and then he's going to expression
with no expression on his face.
He's going to walk off the court as
you sit there scratching your young,
full head of hair, wondering what
the fuck just happened. All right.
I know a lot of people are thinking,
uh, possibly, uh, Oklahoma City who,
I love that team, but a, I'm telling you,
I think the spurs are going to
do it. Um, and I've actually,
because uh,
I was just in a part of the country where
they weren't showing any of the hog or
I couldn't, I was in a hotel room
and I couldn't get any of the hockey.
Every time I was working
it was on and I missed it.
But I kept catching the basketball
games. And I've actually, uh,
NBA hoop is way better, way fucking
better than I've been given a credit for.
The games have been great.
And actually in the end,
even with the timeouts and all the files,
shots does a ton of drama.
It is a great sport.
You know what it is?
I think it's just regular season games
when like playing fucking Toronto and
they're doing that timeout,
timeout shit.
I think I judged them
on the regular season,
which is what a lot of people
do with hockey. Right. Who's
kitten hopes? So my bed.
All right. I have to apologize for
that NBA hoop is actually the shit.
I'm actually, uh, I'm,
I'm back into it and I
really want to see the spurs,
you know,
throat shop,
Oklahoma City after they finish off the
fucking Lakers. And by the way, though,
how right am I about pog with salt?
If you ever seen a fucking face like
that when he gets called for a foul or if
they led a,
I saw one where he didn't touch the ball
and they said it was a Oklahoma's ball
because they claimed it went off him.
Dude, his fucking face. I'm telling you.
Ooh.
And then when he'd dunks
it, he's fucking, you know,
acting like he's in the Wu Tang clan.
That's not who you are. Paul was Saul.
Oh Woo.
Oh, am I going to enjoy watching them
fucking loose? But even as a Celtics fan,
I fucking, I love Coby
Bryant. That guy is the shit.
Um, I saw the, uh, the first Celtics
game. You know, I'm bandwagon Celtics.
I saw a game one. I saw the
highlights of the end of game too.
And uh, once again, I was working
and I missed three and four.
I heard the last game we were up like,
like 16 and nothing and
still lost the Goddamn game.
So I'm going to be watching
that one later on tonight. Um,
but I'm psyched that the
Celtics and sixers are,
are playing in the playoffs just
because it takes me back to the,
the unbelievable.
And he has an underrated for you,
underrated Boston Celtics,
first to Philadelphia,
70 sixers in the early eighties.
Those were some of the, the,
the greatest wars I saw. Everybody
always talks. Celtics Lakers,
they forget about the Celtics.
76 years. I remember one year,
the sixers were up three games to one,
and that was 1981.
And uh,
we ended up coming back and we,
and we beat him for games to three.
The next year they go up again,
three games to one,
then it's three games to two,
then it's three games to three games,
seven in the Boston Garden. And the
sixers came in and were like, fuck this.
And they beat the Celtics.
And next,
I remember that on that week's sports
illustrated, the cover was Dr Jay.
I still remember it says Julius Jams Jinx.
And they had him Duncan and he had this,
go fuck yourself. Look on his face.
Uh, but the six, I think they
lost in the finals to the Lakers.
They even made it that far.
I can't remember.
And then the next year they got
Moses Malone in the shit over.
And that's the one of the most
underrated teams of all times in 1983,
Philadelphia, 76 years. I put
that team up against anybody.
They asked us that classic
when they asked Moses Malone,
what do you think's going to happen in
the playoffs? And he said, full, full,
full meaning we're going to sweep
everybody think they lost one game.
That was the other Celtics got
swept by the Milwaukee Bucks to
another underrated team. Sidney
Moncrief kid. Um, all right.
Did that bore you? Did that make
you turn off the Goddamn thing?
All right. What are we talking about
here? All right. Interesting subject.
Interesting situation.
Hey Bill.
I was dating my girlfriend for three
years since the end of last summer.
We had been on and off.
One Week I say I'm done with her and the
next week I'm taking her out to dinner.
All right. That's codependent. You
know what that just says to me?
Either you're afraid to be alone or
she's fucking the shit out of you.
One of the other, uh, we
didn't speak for about a month.
Then I saw her out with a
guy making out with them.
I lost my cool and punched the guy.
I'm usually a laid back person,
but seeing that drove me crazy.
I realized that if I continued to play
this game with her, I'll lose her.
So for the past month,
I've been great to her wait time out.
Time out. Time out, dude, you already,
you saw her in a bar making out
with another guy. All right?
You, you, you, you got to walk away
from this one. This one's over, dude.
Okay.
You guys, you get together,
you break up, you're, you're,
you're on the outs for a month,
then you're back together.
You don't want to do this. That's like
one of those curtain Courtney fucking, uh,
uh, sid vicious kind of fucking
relationships. You don't need any punch.
This guy in the face.
What did that guy do?
He's doing what guys are supposed to do.
He's trying to get laid.
He doesn't know you, right? You
punched the wrong person if you ask me,
but she can't punch the ladies.
So you've got a dumper
right before you'd dump
or take a really nice,
getting a really nice camera and take
a picture of a face and then go buy a
heavy bag and just put it on that and
just go to the fucking ribs. Um, anyways,
he goes,
I've been great to her dinners,
going out with their parents, doing
all the little things that she loves.
We got close again.
So she's been sleeping at my apartment,
has been and has been leaving things
here and has been asking if she can go,
go to my apartment when I'm not
there. Dude, if she, if this,
this story ends with her bang in some
dude in your bed, in your apartment.
All right. Then when she sleeps
here, she keeps leaving. Well,
I already said that one. Blah,
blah, blah, blah. Alright. Oh well.
Then when she sleeps here,
she keeps leaving things here in
anticipation for her next sleepover,
which is usually the next night.
One of my problems has always been that
she doesn't give me personal space.
So this definitely has been bothering me.
Also,
I hate making out in
public and she loves it.
I think it's immature and unnecessary.
Last night we were out with my
friends and she kept like yelling,
let's make out. And I was so
annoyed. I said, not right now.
She then got off my lap and walked away.
She was doing little annoying things
like this all night. So, uh, so I left.
So now I am very annoyed with this
girl and I'm definitely back in. Uh,
I don't want to see her stage.
Only problem.
My Mom's wedding is this Thursday and
she's going with me and her parents are
invited.
So do I pretend that everything is good
and continue to lie to her and myself
and fake that everything is great.
MMM.
To everybody at this wedding and my
mother or do I man up and go sold to the
wedding and stop faking that
this is the girl from me. Yeah,
he answered you. You, you know what you
gotta do. You get yet dumper. It's it,
it's over.
You know,
you have a wedding to go. Do you want to
have a good time? Maybe you'll meet you.
Maybe. See a nice girl there that
you want to be with [inaudible]
you know,
and then you won't be able to go there.
And then she,
her whole first vibe is she's going to
see you with this other girl and you with
a scowl on your face.
And she's actually gonna feel bad
for the girl because of your energy.
When you're the God damn victim here
as far as I'm concerned. Yeah. Dumper.
Okay.
Dumper. Make a list of Shit you have to
do today. Go to the bank, wash a car,
dump girlfriend,
and just fucking just,
just knock them right off and
just sit down and it's gonna suck.
She's either gonna cry and she's going
to yell at you, but you know what?
In a fucking hour, hour and a
half, it's going to be over.
All right.
You know what you want to do?
Talk to Al Madrigal.
Okay.
Al Madrigal, the Great Al
Madrigal, the daily show zone.
Al Madrigal, a minivan
men podcast. Al Madrigal.
You ask him,
Al Madrigal knows how to break her.
He should have a fucking billboard.
He told me one night's these hilarious
stories of when he was going to break up
with somebody, how he went about it
and it was fucking brilliant. Uh,
he had had the element of surprise. He
was totally prepared. Bing, Bang, boom,
go fuck yourself. It
was over. It was like a,
it was basically the same way a
corporation fires a longtime executive.
The only thing that's missing with the
way Al would break up with somebody with
security walking the person out.
All right,
so email Al Madrigal at minivan.
Men just go to that
podcast and you'll see a,
he'll tell you what to do. He'll tell
you how to, I'm telling you what to do,
which I think you already know and
Al will tell you how to do it. Um,
they should really have
like courses on that.
I don't know why they don't have that,
especially for young people when you
just don't know how to do it. You know,
they should just teach you how to fuck it,
do it the most effective way.
I think I, I break, I broken up
with girls like every possible way
from just never calling them again to
sitting down and watching them fucking cry
their eyes out, which is the
fucking worst to, uh, you know,
getting dumped myself. I've done all
of that shit. I've been the guy where,
you know, you know, I think I'm pulling
the trigger and then she's like,
well good, I don't care. I made out
with somebody six months ago, you know,
and they, you know, which does hurt,
but then also makes you site like, okay,
now I'm definitely doing the right thing
because I had no clue. You're such,
if you have the ability to do something
like that and I can't even pick up on it.
Like, uh, yeah, your poker
face is too fucking dangerous.
Um, so anyways, dude, that sucks.
But you're going to be site when you go
to the wedding and you don't have that
fucking lie tied to your ankle.
Okay.
Macro is just weird. Let's
make out like that seems to me.
And all your friends are there. There's
no like, emotional connection to that.
She just wants to,
she just wants to like engage in that act.
She sounds like she's sort of like
an exhibitionist a little bit. Like,
you know what, that little thing
right there. You know what?
I bet that you could,
uh,
you could probably round third with
her in a bar if it was crowded enough,
you know, if she was standing up and no
one could really see what was going on.
She's one of those girls. All right. And
uh, you know, to each your own, but uh,
that's not the mother
your kids, uh, Daddy,
tell us how you mad mob.
Well,
I was finger banging her at a Denny's
and I was like, wow. The combination is,
and these pigs in a blanket, this must be
the one I'm fresh off a date. Hey Bill,
I'm writing this directly after getting
home from a date. Needless to say,
my depression is higher than normal.
Uh,
I will try to make this as short as
possible. In January, I met this girl,
this lady,
and we really hit it off.
We went out for about two
weeks and everything seemed
great. Then out of nowhere,
she stops responding to my texts,
slash, calls, et cetera. Yeah,
that's one way to do it. Then five months
later, she texted me out of nowhere,
she's drunk and pretends
like nothing happened.
She's a psycho and wants to get
together again. Mistake. Uh,
we went out tonight and we had,
we had fun,
but the goodbye was fairly
awkward realizing that she's
sober and you're not the
person once again, um, I can't
tell if she might be interested,
interested in me or if she just bored
in one. Is someone around exactly.
In any advice for a schmuck like me?
Any advice for a schmuck like me? Uh,
I don't have any advice. I
have a compliment. All right?
You actually know what's going on
and that's a huge thing. All right?
Um, look, this girl is
wherever she is in her life,
and that's not your fault.
You went out on this date with
sincerity in your heart. Okay?
So you're not a schmuck. All
right? You're a patsy. No.
Okay.
I just pictured Lee Harvey
Oswald walking into the, uh,
you walk in in like Lee Harvey Oswald
into the fucking police station with that
big knot in your eye. Oh, so on
the patsy. So on the, I get it,
I'm the guy that this is all getting
blamed on doing this. This isn't you.
You liked this girl.
You thought it was great.
She hurt you when she
didn't text you back.
Five months later she texts
you again and you got excited.
Then she went out with you because she's,
she's trying to figure herself
up and she keeps a, you know,
coming back into your
life, you know, just take,
take comfort in this, know that she's
miserable and lonely too. All right?
You guys aren't right for each other and
you're not a schmuck. You're a good guy.
All right? You didn't go
out there thinking like, I'm
going to fuck this chick,
you know,
and Blah,
Blah Blah and all that evil crap that
guy's usually think you went out there
cause you actually liked her.
You're a good guy and there's nothing
wrong with that. Okay. Some day.
You're going to meet the right girl. This
one isn't it, but you're not a schmuck.
All right. Just stop looking
down at the ground. You know,
staring at your fucking shoes
as other girls.
Right? Fuck her. How's that? Huh? Tell me.
Your friends are going to give you
better advice than that. Um, all right.
Where the hell am I?
Why does it keep fucking doing that?
I swear to God I'm the worst
with this shit. All right,
let's, let's get to the uh,
alright.
stamps.com everybody,
I think you guys have this copy memorized
at this point. Um, I actually just,
just,
uh,
just to let you guys know I have gotten
word that they are going to update their
copies soon. All right? But just
because they have an updated,
the copy doesn't mean
that this isn't a fine,
fine example of American ingenuity,
stamps.com everybody,
Hey, do you hate going to the post
office? Do not like standing in lines.
Do you not like smelling the blue wig
of the old person in front of you?
Um, would it be great if you could somehow
bring the post office into your own
apartment? You know,
you're tented village,
you're waterlogged head, I
dunno where you just, I dunno,
I don't know what the hell I'm talking
about now. stamps.com you can do,
you can do so much more with any
meter and a fraction of a cost.
You can buy and print official US stamps
using gesture, computer and printer.
It's so easy and convenient.
And the best part was stamps.com you'll
never have to go to the post office
again. And that's true. You got this.
You got to scale to weigh anything
that you want to ship, right?
If you've got envelopes,
anything,
you could print out the postage for the
and you can print out all the stamps.
All right. I use stamps.com. It's how I
send out all my DVDs. It's phenomenal.
Um, so if you want a special offer
right now, I've got a special offer.
Use My last name, [inaudible], B U R, r,
a for a no risk trial plus $110 bonus
offer that includes a digital scale and
$55 of free postage.
That's enough money.
That's enough postage to mail everybody
that you hate and to tell them what you
really feel about them. All right,
don't wait. Go to stamps.com now,
before you do anything else,
you click on the radio microphone at the
top of the homepage and type in burpee.
You rr that stamps.com enter [inaudible].
All right.
Okay. Now where do we go from here? Um,
you know what I'm going to do this week,
ladies and gentlemen,
I'm going to go see the dictator and I'm
going to do a bunch of fucking standup.
I'm really excited about,
put my new hour together and for the first
time in a long time actually sat down
and wrote,
wrote out some ideas.
I think I want to try
to do just like a new,
like 20 minute chunk like some of
the shed had been working on and uh,
just tell a couple of stories.
What did I want to talk about?
Oh, I'm going to talk about, uh,
sex scenes in movies and
why think they're stupid?
And that might lead into something,
I dunno what,
I don't know where I'm going
to go with this hour. I mean,
I can't really just sit here.
Am I really going to dedicate another
fucking 20 minutes to ragging on
relationships? This gotta be, there's
gotta be a left turn in there somewhere.
You know,
I'm trying out new shit.
I'm fucking trying to rebuild this Goddamn
carburetor. Just got the parts, uh,
the other day. You know what, here's a
question for all you gearheads out there.
I'm trying to get it. I
got the, uh, I got the, uh,
what do you call it? The uh, Jesus.
I know what the fuck it's called,
the fuel bowl. You know, they got
the primary and the secondary.
I can get both of those off, but then
there's that next piece that's behind it,
you know,
up against the,
basically the main body
of the carburetor and a,
I know there's a gasket
on the other side of that.
And this thing is really old
and it's a piece of shit,
so it's really stuck there.
So I got a small screwdriver
and I'm sorta tapping at it,
but I'm worried that I'm going to do
damage to the metal and I'm going to have
to get it. Machine does. If you have
any ideas on how to fucking get it off,
I don't want to damage the carburetor.
Um,
but this is the thing about doing
all that type of stuff is uh,
there's really no comedy in science.
It's just so fucking,
you know,
reading about the elements and everything.
I guess the comedy is how fucking stupid
I am or blows your mind or whatever.
But like,
um,
I dunno,
I think in a time I'm going to do like
four years worth of science classes
because I've become obsessed with it.
Like my birthday's coming up and I
asked Nina to get me this book on, uh,
like just a electrical,
you know,
for houses and that type of stuff because
electricity is fucking magic to me.
I don't understand it at all. Then I
just watched a couple of youtube videos
and I, I kinda, I kinda get it now.
Like I, I didn't understand like,
like this just a power
source and all the wires are,
are just bringing that
electricity. I, you know,
I didn't know that's basic to you guys
are right. Go Fuck Yourself. What?
I give you shit.
If he didn't know how to write a joke,
I never even thought
about any of this stuff.
Why is it keeps signing me out
of my fucking God damn account
signed back in? What is the
fucking problem anyways,
but I was watching that Eric, the car
guy and he was trying to figure out,
you know, why? You know, the Dome
light and his car was fucked up and a,
and I watched him just take the thing off
on the side of the car and it's just a
little fuse in there and it's just how
the whole thing works in it. Actually,
it started to make sense.
Speaking of Eric, the car guy,
he just uploaded another one,
Eric decar guy just
uploaded another video,
a Chevy Tahoe rear shoe replacement.
I'm such a fucking psycho. I literally
want to get, I want to learn how to weld.
I want to learn how to do all this
shit. All this shit that it, I don't,
my whole fucking life, I watched
these guys, I respected what they did,
but I always thought like, you know, I
remember the kids who took shop class,
you know, they were fucking up in every
other client. Maybe they just had a gift.
I have no idea.
You know what it is.
You just feel like such a bitch as a
guy when you have to bring a, you know,
have somebody come up like,
you know what,
this one actually
sometimes I just tap out,
like I got to get some
screens for a window.
One of the windows has like
an arch on it, so they go, oh,
you got to make like a cardboard cutout
of it to measure it like that. I'm like,
I'm not fucking doing that.
Just come over and do it.
Sometimes you just got to tap out. You
know, like when it comes to dinner,
I can make dinner, but you know,
you just got to tell you, you, you,
you're a woman to go in there and make
it go in there and make me a fucking
sandwich. You know what I
mean? That's why you're here.
I kill it. And then you make it.
Except I don't have to kill it anymore.
Somebody kills it for me.
But I, you know, I bought it.
It's the same goddamn thing now. I'm
like, I'm like the kingpin, you know,
I got this,
this fleet of hitman killing cows and
fucking chickens in that type of shit.
And then they bring it to me, you know,
like Al Pachino, I take the tool myself,
right?
So go in there and prepare it.
That's not sexist is it? Um, all right,
let's talk about some dates
they have coming up. Everybody.
This is my whirlwind tour of,
uh,
of cities. What do we got to
hear? What are we going to hear?
A San Jose June 15th to the 16th,
working with Sacramento's
own Chelsea Peretti, um,
Ontario, California. I'm going to
be at the improv inland empire.
June 29th 30th and July 1st they
Hampton Beach Ballroom Casino,
July 14th and the Newport
yacht and set up in Newport,
Rhode Island,
July 15th.
Don't let that yachting center
name scare you like you.
It's like a $40,000 a plate for Obama's
campaign and everybody's going to be
there wearing Tuxedos.
It's not going to be like that.
It's a giant tent in a parking lot
in Newport, Rhode Island. All right.
You'll get to be able to go down there
and be just as dumb and fucking as you
would be in any other place. All right,
so please come down to that. And uh,
let me actually look up.
I got a couple others.
I got one in Charlotte
and one in Jacksonville,
Florida that I haven't put up yet.
So I'm going to search for this email
if you guys could just be patient.
Um Oh and I got Cincinnati coming up.
There you go.
October 19th
and 20th. I'm going to be a
go bananas and Cincinnati.
Bear with me.
I'm a blowing through here.
Where else? Where else?
The comedy zone in Jacksonville,
Florida. September 27th,
28th and 29th going to the Jaguar game
on that Sunday and I'm going to the
Pittsburgh Steelers,
Cincinnati Bengals game on the other one.
And then the comedy zone in Charlotte,
North Carolina. September 13th,
14th and 15th going to the
Carolina Panthers game that Sunday.
You like that? See, that's how we do the
road. Doesn't have to be miserable people.
Um, all right. Do we have anything
left? I feel like I'm coming up short.
This fucking guy's going to be here any
minute with the goddamn screens. Oh,
58 minutes. I can tap off.
I can leave. Um, all right.
You're not stupid. I already
read that. Oh, here's something.
Here's something a buddy
of mine came up with,
and this has nothing to do with
advertising. This is a friend of mine.
I was trying to get an,
uh, an iPhone application.
He made this new iPhone application.
It's a, it's called Word Nair.
W. O. R. D. I. N. A. I. R. E. Warden Air.
It's a reverse dictionary. So if you think
in like a, you know, what's a word for,
uh, it'll give you a
comprehensive list. Um,
God knows I could do something like that
cause I'm a fucking moron. Um, all right.
Is that the podcast for this week? I
think it is. I got a couple more raw,
anything else that was going on in
my life that I wanted to talk about.
Oh,
I'll get my truck back today after talking
all that shit about learning how to
fix stuff.
I problems with my brakes and uh,
that's not something I'm
going to try and do myself.
I'll fuck with something that,
that after I fuck with it
might not make my truck start.
I'll fuck with something like that.
Like I actually at this point, um,
would have the balls to try
and change a head gasket to,
to put in a new head gasket. You
know, my engine, I think, you know,
what do I have to do? I just take
off the, uh, the air filter housing,
you know, take off the carburetor
off the manifold. Right.
Then I imagine there's some
other shit that's in the way,
but as long as I take it off,
whatever, I probably fuck it up.
But the bottom line is
nobody would get killed.
But when you talk in breaks
and that type of Shit, uh,
there's no fucking way I'm doing
that myself. I'm going to, uh,
that was very least would
have to have somebody there.
So I'm actually getting my
truck back today. Um, but yes,
I do feel like a little bit of a bitch
because I didn't figure it out myself.
But you know, fuck you. I'm trying.
You want to think about is when you
first start to learn how to fix things is
the hardest thing I find is not having
the balls to just start taking it apart.
It's, um, it's the overhead,
the amount of fucking money you have to
spend in tools, but once you buy him,
he got him forever, man. I
want, speaking of which member,
I bragged that I fixed a blender, it's
fucked up. All the lights are coming on.
I don't know what I did to it, but uh,
but I ain't going to quit. I'm underrated.
Overrated, underrated for
this week. Uh, overrated.
Fucking voicemails leaving
them as the most awkward thing.
I've always said that I'm
terrible at leaving them,
but whenever I say that everyone else,
whenever I say that,
everyone else always says it too.
So I'm putting my foot down on the
issue and calling it right now,
leaving a message for
someone on the phone sucks.
There's no way to start your message
normally without sounding like a Douche.
And then five minutes later you realize
you've been trailing on and on while
saying, uh, um, too many times
making you want to kill yourself,
ending with the inevitable
a. Okay, thanks.
By reminding them that you're
still a Douche. Fucking awful. Do.
This is something that's really like
an epidemic in this young generation is
everybody just feeling awkward
and feeling like a Douche.
I don't know what happened to you guys.
I think this last generation of fathers,
they flipped. Like, I'm not going
to beat the shit out of my kid.
Not Hug them and never tell him that I
that I, that I love him. Uh, you know,
I'm going to do all of that shit and you
end up with these people who can't even
fucking leave voicemails.
Okay.
What is so awkward,
you know?
Okay.
I, I, you know what? I have a hard
time getting off the phone. I forget.
I forget what I used to say,
but I don't feel awkward.
Well, I just feel like an idiot, I guess.
So I guess I kind of relate. I just go.
All right. That's it. I'm Outta here.
I will say that, but leaving a
message, I like leaving messages.
I sing on people's voicemails,
you know,
whenever I call up fucking
Blob, Yay. Bobby Kelly,
or in fucking Joey roses,
I call him up and I,
I'll just immediately, I'll
just, whatever comes to my mind,
I'll just start singing. Who's
the con to that? I love the most.
Who's that fucker?
Who eats the toasted Joey?
He's such a big FHEG.
Derosa what's going on?
It's bill. Give me a call back.
You can't click. That's it.
Why don't you try singing?
You can do it for anybody.
Hey Mom, what's up you
sweetie? Thanks for having me.
40 years ago I sent you some flowers.
You didn't call me.
Do you like my siblings better than me?
Click right? Why don't you
do that? Try that search.
Try singing first. Um, all right.
Underrated. Overrated, underrated.
Sitting Down to pee. If you're a guy, uh,
is it that, how old are you?
Is it that hard to stand up?
What is wrong with this fucking
generation of guys? You Know,
Sitting Down To pee,
it's actually easier and you don't get
varicose veins from all those years of
stand. There's nothing better
than just pulling out your Dick.
It just fucking pee and all
over everything. You know,
you fucking shooting the toilet paper
around. It's fucking good time. Um,
anyways, it says the guy who drives
a fucking hybrid. Um, anyways,
there are many benefits to being a guy
and sitting down to peace such as not
having to hear your chick
complain about peeing on the seat,
even though it's on the fucking top of
the bowl and it's not actually the seat.
Yup. Here's a guy. He's, he,
he's literally sitting down to pee, so
his girlfriend will stop yelling at him.
Okay.
I don't know what happened.
People a hundred years ago,
we could hit them with mop handles
and I don't know what happened.
They got organized and we didn't, and
now we're sitting down to pee just still,
they'll stop yelling at us. Um, all
right, number two, if you like me,
if you're like me and you
wake up to pee at night,
you don't have to fuck with your eyes
and turn on the bathroom lights to aim.
Oh Dude.
You take it all the fun out of it.
That's how you train your ear.
All right,
that sounds like the back of the ball.
Where's the water?
That's the floor.
It is one small step.
Um,
number three, not bending down to lift
up the seat out. You know what, dude?
You're a fucking pansy.
Not Bending down to clean off the seat.
Less bending in general. Why don't you
just bend over and Suck Your Own Dick?
He's just sit on the bowl.
You fucking Douche.
Fuck that guy peeing sitting down.
Do you know
what else, sir? What? What, what else
is overrated? Lifting weights. Um,
owning a gun. Chewing tobacco.
Eating steak. What else?
Drinking Scotch. Smoking cigars.
Fixing your own car. What?
What else?
Or what else is fucking overrated?
Everything that makes be
in a guy fucking awesome.
Losing your shit because some guy you
don't know the field goal that really has
no effect on your life talking shit.
Is that all overrated,
Lee Marvin?
Yeah.
The only thing that saved you surge,
you didn't leave your name so that,
that's the only thing that I can say is
I can at least see that there was sort
of some,
some sort of shame in your email.
All right, what do we got here? Why
don't we get here with the man? Great.
I talked about that.
stamps.com I did that and oh,
amazon.com everybody last one here.
amazon.com if, uh, if you guys,
you know, have you buy stuff
on Amazon share, we all do.
If you want to support this podcast,
just go to [inaudible] dot
com click on the podcast page.
You'll see the amazon.com link. Click on
that. And uh, then you're right to Amazon.
You don't have to do anything else.
All right? And if you buy something,
not saying, but if you buy something,
uh, they kicked me a percentage.
It doesn't cost you any extra money and
I take 10% of that and I give it to the
wounded warriors project. That's
how it goes. And that's the deal.
And the last one, oh, sorry.
Game fly.com. All right,
how would you like to have 8,000 games
at your fingertips delivered right to
your door or right to your
PC to week 15 day free trial.
You can play 8,000 games
for nothing. Nada. Zilch.
All right. And that's worth a one day
free trial. They giving you 15 days.
Just go to [inaudible] dot
com slash bill burr and uh,
you'll get the other, my podcast listeners
get this special offer. There you go.
Video Games. Look, I
hooked you up. Video Games,
amazon.com post office in
your own house. And, uh,
you'll make a better steak this weekend.
What else do you want from me?
You want more, don't you?
Well, go fuck yourself.
Cause that's the end of
this podcast. All right. Um,
did I forget anything? I don't think
I did. That is it. That is all,
and now it's on to Chicago
and let's win there.